[Música]
Jair bolsonaro testificó en una
audiencia por la investigación en la que
lo acusan de quedarse con joyas de
Arabia Saudita cuando era presidente de
Brasil el Antiguo mandatario acudió al
cuartel general de la Policía Federal en
Brasilia Tenemos reporte de nuestro
corresponsal
en Colombia el presidente Gustavo Petro
pide acelerar la evacuación de 2.500
familias que viven alrededor del nevado
del Ruiz el hecho ocurre el mismo día en
el que el volcán tuvo el mayor sismo
registrado desde 1985 cuando una
erupción sepultó el pueblo de armero
y por segunda noche consecutiva la
policía de Israel irrumpió en la
mezquita de Jerusalén mientras los
musulmanes oraban durante el ramadán
desde Estados Unidos y Turquía hasta el
grupo jamás han rechazado estos
operativos
Buenas noches Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 Mi nombre es María Clara
calle y es un placer acompañarlos
iniciamos en Brasil el expresidente Jair
bolsonaro fue este miércoles al cuartel
general de la Policía Federal de
Brasilia para testificar en una de las
investigaciones que tiene en contra lo
acusan de haberse quedado con las joyas
y regalos que el rey de Arabia Saudita
le dio al Estado brasileño en 2021
cuando bolsonaro era presidente nuestro
periodista Brasil Pierre nos amplía
fue interrogado durante tres horas en
una comisaria de Brasilia para declarar
sobre los regalos que él y su esposa
recibieron el rey de Arabia Saudita unas
joyas valoradas en más de tres millones
de dólares habían sido incautadas por la
aduana brasileña en la mochila de un
ayudante de gobierno cuando volvió de
Arabia Saudita y varios funcionarios
intentaron después recuperarlas sin
éxito otros dos paquetes de regalos han
sido devueltos al estado en los últimos
días por los abogados de revolucionaron
después de una decisión del tribunal
Federal de compras ella bolsonaro es
sospechado de intentar apropiarse
regalos que pertenecen a la colección
presidencial y de intentar hacerlos
entrar de contrabando a Brasil este caso
afecta gravemente su imagen como líder
anticorrupción pero en total él tiene
que responder de 16 acciones en la
justicia cualquiera de ellas podría
impedirle hacer elegido más que nunca Su
futuro político está en manos de la
justicia pasamos a Colombia donde el
presidente Gustavo Petro ordenó la
evacuación de 2.500 familias ubicadas en
zonas de riesgo por el volcán nevado del
Ruiz la alerta en este momento se
mantiene en naranja y este jueves se
registró un sismo de 3,9 en la magnitud
de richter El mayor de 1985 lluís Muñoz
tiene los detalles
Esta es la vista desde el municipio
colombiano de herveo ubicado muy cerca
del volcán nevado del Ruiz que se
encuentra en alerta naranja los vecinos
sienten las consecuencias que se siente
a veces por ahí así algo de ceniza
sí y no se acuestas como nervioso
sienten miedo y piden ayuda yo siento
que en estos momentos nosotros estamos
en una zona de riesgo y necesitamos
mucha colaboración de del gobierno
departamental porque tenemos unas vías
de acceso muy malas para en caso de una
evacuación desde la alcaldía de berbeo
aseguran que están siguiendo todos los
protocolos de prevención
todos los boletines que que nos han
enviado y hemos hecho Pues todos los
protocolos necesarios para el tema de
evacuaciones de albergue de puntos de
encuentro este miércoles el presidente
Gustavo Petro ordenó acelerar la
evacuación de 2500 familias que se
encuentran en zona de riesgo Mientras
tanto el servicio geológico colombiano
mantiene la alerta naranja y la unidad
nacional para la gestión del riesgo de
desastres hizo una actualización
os preocupa es que en este caso los
sismos cada vez se acercan más al cráter
Y esa según los vulcanólogos no es que
sea la mejor de las señales de hecho
este miércoles hubo un sismo de magnitud
de 3,9 El mayor desde 1985 cuando se
produjo la erupción más mortal del
volcán nevado del Ruiz que dejó más de
23.000 personas muertas
el gobierno nicaragüense de Daniel
Ortega prohibió los viacrucis de
cuaresma alegando razones de seguridad
pero los críticos creen que se trata de
una nueva escalada represiva contra la
iglesia católica de ese país debido al
veto las parroquias se vieron forzadas a
realizar las actividades propias de esta
época dentro de los templos y bajo
vigilancia policial la Semana Santa en
el país centroamericano fue marcada por
la expulsión del sacerdote panameño
donaciano Alarcón medios locales
refieren que su expulsión se debe a que
el sacerdote mencionaba durante sus
homilías al encarcelado obispo Rolando
Álvarez condenado a 26 años de prisión
por traición a la patria así se
pronunció la Iglesia Católica panameña
sobre la expulsión del religioso
Estas son las cosas que a veces no
entendemos de quienes a veces
ostentan el poder verdad y yo creo que
es sobre todo libertad religiosa porque
según lo que pudimos conocer fue
precisamente eso desde después de la
celebración fue tomado
Es cierto que no le hicieron daño pero
fue expulsado del territorio
nicaragüense Argentina regresa a unasur
y el presidente de Alberto Fernández
pidió una renovación del organismo el
mandatario viajó a Chile para conmemorar
los 205 años de independencia de ese
país Desde allí Fernández le pidió a su
homólogo Gabriel borich que trabajen
juntos en reorganizar el bloque regional
para que reúna a diferentes ideologías
de Suramérica y sirva a la vez al
desarrollo económico el grupo promovido
por Hugo Chávez entró en crisis en 2017
y 2018 cuando varios gobiernos
conservadores se retiraron por sus
diferencias frente a la crisis de
Venezuela ahora una Sur parece tomar un
nuevo aire con el regreso de Argentina y
Brasil
segundo día de confrontaciones en la
mezquita de alaxa en Jerusalén la
versión de wak la organización islámica
que administra el complejo Es que la
policía israelí irrumpió con granadas de
aturdimiento y Balas de goma y sacó a
los musulmanes que oraban durante el
ramadán luego algunos de los fieles
arrojaron objetos a los uniformados es
el segundo día consecutivo en el que la
policía israelí arremete contra la
mezquita ayer realizó una redada y la
media luna roja Palestina afirmó que 12
palestinos resultaron heridos desde la
franja de gasas respondieron lanzando
cohetes contra Israel mientras que
Turquía es uno de los países que
rechazan el ataque contra alaxa
[Música]
me gustaría expresar nuestra tristeza e
ir a por estas acciones terroristas de
la policía contra la mezquita de alaxa y
los musulmanes palestinos durante el mes
sagrado del ramadán
atacar a los civiles con bombas de
sonido porras y Balas de plástico es una
Clara señal de injusticia se ve
claramente que detrás de esta ola de
violencia que la administración israelí
ha infringido a pesar de todas las
advertencias están los problemas que
enfrentan la política interior
la invasión estadounidense en Irak en
2003 también fue una amenaza para
Babilonia una de las ciudades más
antiguas de la humanidad las tropas
extranjeras crearon una base en las
proximidades de las ruinas que se Adam
hussein estaba reconstruyendo Maki
Mohamed de 56 años ha vivido toda su
vida en la zona y ha sido testigo de
cómo los turistas vuelven a este lugar
después de dos décadas nuestra enviada
especial Catalina Gómez Ángel nos cuenta
la historia
de tanto repetirlo Maki Mohamed memorizó
la inscripción que el ex dictador Sadam
husein o derrotó tallar en los ladrillos
utilizados en la reconstrucción de la
antigua Babilonia en 1988 construyeron
esta parte más atrás fue en 1989
como lo hizo Nabucodonosor II
considerado el más grande de quienes
reinaron el Imperio Babilonia
se obsesionó con dejar su legado en este
lugar considerado cuna de la humanidad
construyó su Palacio en lo alto de las
ruinas a las que quería devolver su
grandeza
la nueva Babilonia duró 2600 años Fue
obra del famoso rey de la nueva
Babilonia que empezó a construirla en el
año 605 antes de Cristo
y su familia ha trabajado en Babilonia
por generaciones su mayor preocupación
es la conservación del lugar
muchos de los turistas iraquíes que la
visitan son extremadamente jóvenes y no
son conscientes de la importancia de
cuidarla pero su mayor dolor de cabeza
fue durante la invasión estadounidense
en 2003 las tropas extranjeras
levantaron uno de sus campamentos en los
alrededores de la ciudad estaban dentro
de la ciudad antigua había vehículos
blindados cerca del monumento del león
su aeropuerto estaba detrás de estos
árboles sus vehículos y soldados
tuvieron un impacto negativo en la
ciudad antiguamente fue encarcelado por
dos meses la razón para la detención fue
pedirle a una soldado que no se llevara
uno los ladrillos milenarios me ataron
las manos a la espalda y me pusieron una
bolsa negra en la cabeza me llevaron a
su base cerca de la cuerda de estar y
luego me metieron en la cárcel me ataron
las manos durante aproximadamente un mes
me torturaron y eso me afectó
negativamente me presionaron los huesos
me quedan estas cavidades dos décadas
después la vida ha recuperado una cierta
normalidad cada días visitado por más
turistas algunos de ellos extranjeros
que poco a poco vuelven a regresar para
alegría de Maki Mohamed Siempre listo a
explicar cómo era esa Babilonia una de
las ciudades más antiguas de la
civilización
llegamos al final de las noticias sigan
con nosotros Porque volvemos en minutos
[Música]